Democrats and my fellow liberals it's
the people we supposedly care about are
the victims of crime it's those folks
who are voting for more security more
safety more and better cops and it's the
white liberals who want to defund the
police this is a big Achilles heel for
the Democrats is it not oh they need to
get out in front of it they need to I
want a Democrat stand up and say you
know some people belong in jail
you know the rapists the murderers
I think that's very interesting I'm
gonna go out on a limb some people do
belongings yeah but you know the fact
that he even called out the one person
clapped on that that some people deserve
in jail because Liberals are all afraid
of each other but there was one same
probably conservative in the crowd he
hears oh rapists should be in jail
that's pretty good
anybody for rapists in jail
and Bill's going yeah rapists should be
in jail